you bros voted if I was an anime
character what would I be an anime
schoolgirl you hear that a Slee
I'm an anime schoolgirl thanks to you
bros voting on twitter thank you so much
there's so many cool animes but anyway
school girl just what I wanted
thank you appreciate it so thanks to
crunchyroll we bring in that to life so
that's what this video is going to be
but first for those of you who don't
know about crunchyroll it's the
streaming service of anime and drama
it's a service that I personally use as
well so I'm really happy to have them a
sponsor and making this pretty pie anime
a real thing huge thanks to them I'm a
fan of anime myself what can I say I
enjoy a good berserk sound like a mom
trying to say like yeah I watch anime I
enjoy a good GTO really great shows
they're all available on crunchyroll and
i would love to hear your bros opinion
on them so check them out they have over
25,000 anime episodes I'm sure you'll
find something that you'll enjoy but not
just that you're supporting the Japanese
anime industry by supporting crunchable
cuz every season they're bringing in the
freshest anime straight from Japan so
basically if you check out the link in
the description crunchyroll.com slash
pills you get a 30-day free trial to
check it out and see if you like it you
basically can watch as much anime you
want for 30 days with no ads 1080p baby
and the newest episodes air one after
they are up in Japan with professional
subtitles I think that's pretty cool I
really enjoy it so maybe you will as
well and thanks again for crunchyroll
for making this happen now let's roll
the clip
hey what you doing not much just hanging
hey what are you guys talking about oh
hi
just chatting about the big game tonight
why do you get what we're talking about
I was just trying to talk to we all know
you're obsessed with him everyone sees
you taking photos of him everywhere no I
don't why don't you just leave him alone
for once he'll never be yours get over
it
alright girls take it easy now yeah
haha
he's not yours you'll never come even
close to what I feel for him they'll
miss you little rat
oh this is all your fault yeah yeah
ah
and he lost words little freak suck on
my laser big
she was right I'll never have him but if
I can't have him I must be